alors je me souviens de du président
johnson qui avait des c quand même
humiliant d'être tenu en échec par des
petits hommes en pyjama
dans cette phrase ya tout une certaine
façon je méprise mon adversaire et je
m'étonne que je n'arrive pas à les
écraser parce que je ne comprends pas
parce que je ne sais pas ce qu'il motive
on parle de guerre asymétrique bon
qu'est ce que c'est la symétrie c'est à
dire qu'on n'est plus égaux il ya
quelque chose de décalé la véritable
asymétrie elle est idéologique si je
suis prêt à mourir pour la cause pour
laquelle je combats je ferai toujours
mieux que vous qui faisait toucher votre
paye qui venait toucher votre
mortgage de la baraque que vous allez
acheter aux états unis ou de la carte
verte qui va vous permettre de devenir
enfin sur la voie d'une citoyenneté
américaine il ya une différence
fantastique voilà ça c'est très
important quand mcchrystal général
intelligent qui a été payé par le
congrès pour faire en 2008 une
habile ans
il l'a fait il a publié dans le
washington post et il a dit écoute et
90% de nos troupes ne sortent jamais des
bases quand ils sortent c'est en force à
tel point ils ont la trouille qu'il ya
un camion suicide qui les bougies donc
aucun contact avec la population
d'ailleurs personne ne l'a d'interprète
et il leur a dit cette phrase je vais
vous l'aviez en anglais guys in
afghanistan transitent les mecs vous
n'êtes pas en afgha vous êtes en transit
[Musique]